what's always been donald trump's
megaphone
now silenced his personal twitter
account permanently suspended the
company says
due to the risk of further incitement of
violence
he responded using the official
presidential account
accusing twitter of banning free speech
and trying to silence him
those tweets were removed the ground is
shifting
in american politics so help me god
congratulations mr president this
tradition of the transition of power the
handshake between incoming and outgoing
presidents
will be missing this year trump will
skip the inauguration
and the next president is pretty happy
with that
one of the few things he and i have ever
agreed on
it's a good thing him not showing up
he's been an embarrassment
to the country embarrassed us around the
world
not worthy not worthy to hold that
office
if we were six months out we should be
moving everything
to get him out of office and teaching
him again
invoke trying to invoke the 25th
amendment whatever it took
to get him out of office but i am
focused now
on us taking control however little time
is left congress is pushing ahead
with impeaching trump for the second
time a vote
likely next week and almost certain to
succeed
so we can have a little asterisk in
history he's always wanted to do stuff
that's never been done before
there's never been a president impeach
twice before
so let's impeach him give him what he
wants
even after this belated concession my
focus now turns to ensuring a smooth
orderly and seamless transition of power
the pressure mounts to round off a week
that's defied belief
how about this from the speaker of the
house nancy pelosi on her conversation
with the head of the military
to discuss the available precautions for
preventing an unstable president
from initiating military hostilities or
accessing the launch codes and ordering
a nuclear strike
the situation of this unhinged president
could not be more dangerous
she wrote where protesters brought chaos
on wednesday
the preparations for the inauguration
have now resumed the question is what
donald trump's absence from this
inauguration stage
says to america is it the action of a
man who truly does now believe that joe
biden is the legitimate next president
or does it encourage those who've
already been mobilized
into action by his words the flag at the
capitol flies at half-mast in honour of
police officer brian siknik
killed in the mayhem on wednesday a
murder inquiry
has now begun
america is a very different place from
the one that witnessed the last
changeover in the white house
trump's time is running out and the
reality tv president will want to make
sure he remains the star of this show
until the very end greg milam sky news
washington